NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Our lecture today actually has
us backtrack a little bit to a
concept which is actually more
fundamental than that of
differentiability.
It's a topic which is called
'continuous functions'.
In other words, our lecture
today is concerned with a
topic called Continuity.
And actually, the topic of
continuity had its roots way
back at the beginning of our
course when we first raised
the question: does the limit of
'f of x' as 'x' approaches
'a' equal 'f of a'?
Remember, when we first started
talking about the
limit concept, our intuitive
approach was to say, look-it,
as 'x' gets arbitrarily close
to 'a', 'f of x' gets
arbitrarily close to 'f of a'.
And we saw that this particular
definition had a
few loopholes in it, even though
intuitively this is
what we would have liked.
And so what I want to do today
is to see what happens if we
can be sure that the limit of 'f
of x' as 'x' approaches 'a'
equals 'f of a'.
What is implied if this happens
to be a true statement?
And my first claim is that it is
implicitly implied that 'f
of a' must at least
make sense.
Otherwise, we wouldn't have
written it over here.
In other words, 'f' must be
defined when 'x' equals 'a'.
'f of a' must be defined.
Now to correlate that with
material that we've had
previously, let's go back
to an example that we've
discussed before, or at least
an example which is close to
something we've studied
before.
Let's define 'f of x' to be 'x
squared minus 1' over 'x - 1'.
Now you see as long as 'x' is
not equal to 1, we can cancel
'x - 1' from both numerator and
denominator, leaving this
equal to 'x + 1'.
And we then see what?
That the limit of 'f of
x' as 'x' approaches
1 is equal to 2.
On the other hand, notice that
'f of 1' turns out to be 0/0
in this case, which
is undefined.
In other words, in this
particular case, the limit of
'f of x' as 'x' approaches 1
is not equal to 'f of 1' if
only because 'f of 1'
isn't even defined.
And again, by way of a review,
let's look at this thing
pictorially.
Remember, 'x squared minus 1'
over 'x - 1' is 'x + 1' except
when 'x' equals 1.
Consequently, to graph 'y'
equals 'x squared minus 1'
over 'x - 1', we simply graph
'y' equals 'x + 1' with the
point corresponding to 'x'
equals 1, meaning the point 1
comma 2 deleted.
In other words, this point
deleted is the graph 'y'
equals 'x squared minus
1' over 'x - 1'.
You see again there is no
definition at 'x' equals 1
because this point is missing.
It would be the 0/0 form.
Now, to be sure, we can clean
this up in the sense that we
could define a new function 'g
of x' to be 'x squared minus
1' over 'x - 1' as long as 'x'
is not equal to 1 and define
it to be 2 when 'x' equals
1, which, by the way,
geometrically is just a fancy
way of writing the equation of
the line 'y' equals 'x + 1'.
In other words, all we're saying
is that letting 'g of
x' be 2 when 'x' equals 1 plugs
the little hole to the
periods over here.
Now again, I hope that this
seems fairly familiar from our
discussion on limits, but for
the time being, all I want us
to see is that as soon as you
write down that the limit of
'f of x' as 'x' approaches 'a'
equals 'f of a', you at least
imply that 'f of a'
must be defined.
Let's see another property
that's implied by our
definition.
I claim, as you might expect,
that if the limit of 'f of x'
as 'x' approaches 'a' is 'f of
a', that means that 'f of x'
is near 'f of a' when
'x' is near 'a'.
In other words, my claim is that
the curve 'y' equals 'f
of x' is unbroken in
a neighborhood
of 'x' equals 'a'.
And to see what I mean by
that, let's look at this
picture over here.
Suppose, for example, that our
curve 'y' equals 'f of x'--
let me darken this up so that we
can see it a little better.
Suppose that curve had a break
at 'x' equals 'a', OK?
Now, let's say 'f of
a' is over here.
What I could do is now pick an
interval surrounding 'f of a',
if there was a break over here,
such that this band
never touched or included
the top curve here.
Now notice, from this point of
view, that no matter how close
'x' gets to 'a', as long as 'x'
is greater than 'a', 'f of
x', which is up here on this
dark curve, can never be
within epsilon of 'f of a'.
In other words, if there's a
break in the curve I could
always fix it up so that the
limit of 'f of x' as 'x'
approaches 'a' is not
equal to 'f of a'.
At any rate, with these two
properties as motivation, let
us now give our basic
definition.
And the basic definition is
simply this: a function 'f' is
called continuous that 'x'
equals 'a' precisely if the
property that we were discussing
is present, namely,
if the limit of 'f of x' as
'x' approaches 'a' is
equal to 'f of a'.
We generalize this definition
and say 'f' is called
continuous on the entire
interval 'I', or on the
interval 'I', if the limit of 'f
of x' as 'x' approaches 'a'
is equal to 'f of a' for
each 'a' in 'I'.
In other words, notice that
our first definition is a
local property.
Namely, we define continuous or
continuity at a given value.
And then if the function happens
to be continuous at
every point, then we call the
function itself continuous.
What the thing means pictorially
is that if the
function is continuous at 'x'
equals 'a', it means that in
terms of the graph of the
function, that in a
neighborhood of the point 'a'
comma 'f' of a on the graph,
in a neighborhood of that point,
in other words, in a
sufficiently small interval
surrounding that point, the
curve itself must be unbroken.
Now, you see, this may
sound trivial.
Remember, when we first started
talking about limits,
we had the feeling that limit of
'f of x' as 'x' approaches
a should always equal
'f of a'.
And the reason for this was that
instinctively we seem to
always think of continuous
functions.
We think of what?
Things changing in such a way
the graph of the change is
unbroken even though, of course,
there are places where
discontinuities occur.
At any rate, what I'm saying
is that many of the results
that I now want to discuss
with you, which are very
important properties of
continuous functions, may seem
self-evident because we keep
thinking about any function as
being continuous.
But I will try to emphasize the
fact that these properties
are not true if the function
is not continuous.
I also would like to show a
balance between geometric
ideas and analytic ideas.
In other words, let me start off
by seeing what things seem
to follow about continuous
functions based primarily on
the graph idea.
For example, I claimed that
continuous functions assume
their maximum and minimum values
on any closed interval.
Now, this sounds like a big
mouthful, and it also sounds
kind of trivial.
You say doesn't any function
have a maximum and minimum
value on a closed interval?
And the answer is no.
For example, take the
curve 'y' equals '1
over ''x - 1' squared''.
Notice that when 'x' is 1, 'y'
is infinite, which means that
if we graph this particular
function, we find that the
graph does something
like this.
In other words, it goes--
it jumps up here, comes
back, et cetera.
Now, what is the highest value
or what is the highest point
on our graph here?
Well, notice that the graph
is broken here.
It's discontinuous when
'x' equals 1.
Notice that the curve
rises to infinity.
In other words, the maximum
value is undefined on this
particular closed interval.
You see there's a
jump over here.
Of course, the fact that this
is an infinite jump may make
you feel uneasy if
you don't feel
comfortable with infinity.
So let me paraphrase this just
a little bit in terms of a
finite jump.
Let me write down the
following function.
Let's think of the function 'f
of x' equals 'x' if 'x' is
less than 1.
Then as soon as 'x' is at
least as big as 1, the
function becomes 'minus x'.
In other words, graphically,
we have the line 'y' equals
'x' from 0 up to 1, but
not including 1.
And then at 1, the function
jumps down to minus 1 and
becomes the line 'y'
equals 'minus x'.
Let's look, for example,
at the closed interval
again from 0 to 2.
What is the biggest value?
What is the maximum that the
function can have if 'x' is
between 0 and 2?
Well, notice that as 'x' gets
closer and closer to 1, 'f of
x' gets closer and closer to 1,
But 'f of x' never equals
exactly 1, because when
'x' is 1, the curve
jumps down to here.
In other words, notice that as
'x' gets arbitrarily close to
1, 'f of x' increases and gets
arbitrarily close to but
never equals 1.
In other words, notice that by
picking 'x' to be less than 1,
we can make 'f of x' as close
to 1 as we want, but we can
never make it exactly equal to
1 because of this jump which
takes place over here.
You see, this discontinuity
causes us a little bit of
difficulty.
By the way, we can use
this example from
another point of view.
If we just look at the part
where it says 'f of x' is
equal to 'x' where 'x' is less
than 1, that means that we'll
just look at this part
of the curve.
Notice that this part of
the curve is unbroken.
And yet as 'x' approaches 1, 'f
of x' approaches but never
equals 1, which means that to
get the maximum value in here,
I would have to include the
end point 'x' equals 1.
In other words, notice that
even if the function is
continuous, if the interval is
open, it may not assume the
maximum value.
In other words, you may not be
able to find the value of 'x'
in that interval such as the
function will be maximum at
that particular value.
Now again, this is making a
mountain out of a mole hill in
terms of your intuition because
these are result which
I'm sure you believe
are true anyway.
In other words, it
seems to be true.
But all I hope is that these
little examples here show you
what the importance of
continuity is, because as we
progress later in our work,
these so called fine points
are going to become crucial
in many of our proofs.
And by the way, I think it's a
truism to say that if you make
fine points seem very, very
important before you get to
use them and don't emphasize
them, people tend to think
that you overestimated
your case.
So I prefer not to beat this to
death and wait until such
times in our course that we need
these results before I
emphasize them more.
So these are results which are
in the textbook, which I'll
test you on in the exercises and
the like, but just want to
go through with you now so that
you get an overall idea.
Another result that's rather
clear geometrically is
something called the
intermediate value theorem.
Suppose that 'f' is continuous
on the closed interval from
'a' to 'b'.
And without loss of generality,
let's suppose 'f
of a' is less than 'f of b'.
The same kind of an argument
would hold if 'f of b' were
less than 'f of a', but I just
need some sort of an
orientation.
Now I say let 'm' be any number
such that m is what?
Between 'f of a' and 'f of b'.
In other words, 'm' is greater
than 'f of a' but
less than 'f of b'.
You see, if 'f of b' were less
than 'f of a', I would just
reverse the inequality
signs here.
At any rate, what my claim is
that we can find the number
'c' in the open interval from
'a' to 'b' such that 'f of c'
equals 'm'.
Again, this may sound
kind of complicated.
All it says in terms of
a picture is this.
If our curve goes from point 1
to point 2 where the height of
'p1' is 'f of a' and the height
of 'p2' is 'f of b',
then it must assume every
intermediary height between 'f
of a' and 'f of b' on that
particular interval.
Again, you can think of
that in terms of an
automobile, if you want.
If an automobile goes from a
speed of 20 miles an hour to a
speed of 30 miles per hour in
what we think of as being
continuous motion, then at some
time in that interval, it
must've had any particular
speed you want to mention
between 20 and 30 miles.
In other words, we don't
visualize a car going from 20
miles an hour to 30 miles an
hour, say, without at one time
having passed the speed
of 27 miles per hour
or some such thing.
And geometrically, you see,
this proof is very simple,
namely, draw the line
'y' equals 'm'.
And now what you're saying is
you want to get from this
point to this point.
And the idea is that the only
way you can get from this
point to this point without
crossing this line is if
someplace along the way, you
jump over this line.
In other words, geometrically,
all you're saying is lookit,
if I have to join 'p1' and 'p2'
with an unbroken line,
then I must cross the line
'y' equals 'm' someplace.
By the way, notice I say that at
least one place, the curve
could have done something
like this, for example.
But the important
point is what?
There's at least one number
'c' such that 'f
of c' equals 'm'.
Again, somebody might think in
terms of an end run and say
couldn't we have done something
like this and not
cross this line?
That brings us back again
to our concept of
single-valuedness.
In other words, notice, if we
remove the restriction that 'f
be a' single-valued function,
in other words, if 'f' can
double back, notice that if we
think of the line 'y' equals
'm' as being endless, the
point remains what?
That you must someplace cross
this line in going
from 'p1' to 'p2'.
But if we remove the
single-valued restriction,
then the point at which
you cross this line
would not have to be--
see, in this case, 'c' would
not be in the open interval
from 'a' to 'b' since 'f'
is not single- valued.
And what I'm hoping this
discussion does for us is
gives us a good geometric
feeling as to what is
happening in terms of a
continuous function.
By the same token, remember
our basic definition of
continuity goes back to
our concept of limit.
And our concept of limit has
been cemented down fairly
firmly from an analytical point
of view, and that means
that we can also see these
things theoretically as well
as pictorially.
And hopefully what we will do
is combine pictorial and
analytic aspects to
the best possible
advantage for solving problems.
But to show you what I mean by
this, let's look at a few
analytical properties of
continuous functions.
For example, suppose 'f' and 'g'
are both continuous at 'x'
equals 'a'.
And suppose we define 'h' to
be the sum of 'f' and 'g'.
In other words, 'h of x' is 'f
of x' plus 'g of x', OK?
Let's compute the limit of 'h
of x' as 'x' approaches 'a'.
By definition, the limit of 'h
of x' as 'x' approaches 'a' is
the limit of the quantity 'f
of x' plus 'g of x' as 'x'
approaches 'a'.
Now, if we look at this
particular expression, notice
that because of our theorems on
limits, we can do an awful
lot with this without having
to make any recourse to our
picture at all.
For example, notice that we can
say right away that since
the limit of a sum is the sum
of the limits, this is the
limit of 'f of x' as 'x'
approaches 'a' plus the limit
of 'g of x' as 'x'
approaches 'a'.
Secondly, since 'f' and 'g' are
continuous at 'x' equals
'a', by definition of continuous
that 'x' equals
'a', this says that the limit of
'f of x' as 'x' approaches
'a' is 'f of a'.
The limit of 'g of x' as 'x'
approaches 'a' is 'g of a'.
Therefore, this expression is
'f of a' plus 'g of a'.
But by the definition of 'h',
this is just 'h of a'.
And if we now look at
this, we see what?
That the limit of 'h of x'
as 'x' approaches 'a'
equals 'h of a'.
Notice that this result came
about under the assumption
that 'f' and 'g' were both
continuous that 'x' equals
'a', and what have we
proven over here?
This is precisely the statement
that 'h' is
continuous at 'x' equals 'a'.
In other words, what we've now
proven analytically is that a
sum of two continuous
functions is
a continuous function.
By induction, we could prove
this for the sum
of more than two.
We can in a similar way by using
limit theorems prove
things like the product of two
continuous functions is
continuous, et cetera.
We also were on the verge of a
topic like this when we talked
about differentiability
sometime back.
Namely, I claim that there is
an interesting connection
between differentiable and
continuous, and that the
connection is that any
differentiable function is
continuous.
And by the way, the proofs
utilizes that which we used in
our first lecture on derivatives
in this block.
Namely, we take the expression
'f' of--
we want to show that if 'f prime
of a' exists, that 'f'
must be continuous at
'x' equals 'a'.
That means we want to show that
the limit of 'f of x' as
'x' approaches 'a' is 'f of
a', and that's the same as
saying we want to show that this
difference approaches 0
and the limit.
And the trick is we take 'f of
x' minus 'f of a' and write it
as ''f of x' minus 'f of a'
divided by 'x - a'' times 'x -
a', the idea being that we'll
now take the limit as 'x'
approaches 'a'.
The limit of a product is the
product of the limits.
The limit of this as 'x'
approaches 'a' is just going
to be 'f prime of a'.
That's our definition
of derivative.
And the limit of 'x - a' as 'x'
approaches 'a' is just 0.
In other words, putting
these steps together,
look what we get.
The limit as 'x' approaches 'a',
'f of x' minus 'f of a',
is the limit as 'x' approaches
'a' of this bracketed
expression ''f of x' minus 'f of
a' over 'x - a'' times the
limit of 'x - a' as 'x'
approaches 'a'.
By definition, 'f' being
differentiable at 'a' means
that this limit exists and is,
in fact, 'f prime of a'.
But any finite number
times 0 is still 0.
And therefore, it follows that
the limit of 'f of x' as 'x'
approaches 'a' is 'f of a'.
There's a legitimate analytic
proof that differentiability
implies continuity.
Now, it's not necessarily true
that continuity implies
differentiability.
And you see even though you
can prove these things
analytically, if you don't
form some picture in your
mind, you frequently will my
wind up memorizing results
rather than having a
feeling for them.
What I mean by having pictures
and proofs coexist is this.
Instead of saying to yourself,
let's see, continuity is a
weaker condition than
differentiability, it's a
strong-- which one is it?
You say look-it.
We identified continuity
with unbroken.
Remember, continuous
means unbroken.
What did differentiable mean?
Differentiable meant that the
curve had a tangent line, and
that, in turn, meant that
the curve was smooth.
In other words, we may think
of differentiable as the
geometric analog of smoothness,
continuity as the
geometric analog of
unbrokenness.
And now I think it's very easy
to see pictorially that a
smooth curve must be unbroken,
but an unbroken curve doesn't
have to be smooth.
And in fact, a very trivial
illustration of this is the
graph 'y' equals the absolute
value of 'x'.
You see, well, what
happens here?
At the origin, notice that we
have a sharp corner, but that
the curve itself is
unbroken there.
You see, I can draw the curve
without taking the pencil off
the paper, the chalk
off the board.
That's what continuity
means from an
intuitive point of view.
Yet I have a sharp corner.
It's not smooth here.
That's why I write smooth
in quotation marks.
Hopefully, the textbook,
together with our exercises,
will make this much
clear to you.
But notice again in terms of
the picture how an unbroken
curve doesn't have to be smooth,
but a smooth curve has
to be unbroken.
Now, the point is we
could say much more
about continuous functions.
I think that all we have
to say, though, has
already been said.
It'll be reinforced
in the text.
We'll have exercises on this.
But the important thing for now
is to understand what we
mean by continuous, how we will
use it in the future, and
at any rate, we'll be talking
about that more later.
And so until next
time, goodbye.
NARRATOR: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.